samuel
I have to ask you some questions
and the leaders of tomorrow will come out here they
are the new ones well luck you are going to
need paradise boy
hello my name is samuel I said the
waiter
[Music] he
looks like a minister
[Music]
these people never have anything good
what can you tell me  of this why
we believe that it is about the murder weapon
[Music]
as
I really believe that others believe that we are
[Music] it
is what we hide from the fashionistas,
maybe about 20 countries
is that I have nothing to confess
[Music]
I know
you're going to get to be with her you hear me
when gunpowder meets fire
I can do it something
explodes
who was
this is not a point
do you have any more questions